[Música]
en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología soy valentina torre
sánchez y es un gusto acompañarlos
iniciamos en américa latina donde
continúan los ataques cibernéticos
conocidos como ransomware o secuestro de
datos lo que los delincuentes hacen en
esta modalidad es justamente secuestrar
información de un usuario ya sea una
persona una entidad o incluso un
gobierno para luego pedir un rescate
transformar en américa latina es un
fenómeno que ha existido por el rededor
de una década hemos visto desde el 2015
2016 que muchas compañías especializadas
en ciberseguridad están reportando que
ha habido un incremento entre el 150 y
200 por ciento anual de los incidentes
de ransomware en países como brasil
colombia méxico chile perú y costa rica
es un fenómeno es una realidad en la que
gobiernos empresas y personas nos
estamos enfrentando y lo importante es
formar acción y cambiar de mentalidad y
empezar a tomar
diferentes acciones en cuanto a
inversión de recursos humanos tecnología
inversiones financieras que nos permitan
por supuesto
sobrellevar todos estos asuntos el
ransomware usa un programa malicioso que
impide a los usuarios acceder a sus
sistemas o archivos hasta que paguen
determinada cantidad de dinero y de
acuerdo con plataformas especializadas
se calcula que los criminales han
conseguido unos 120 millones de dólares
con esta modalidad de crimen de acuerdo
con el informe de amenazas cibernéticas
2022 de la firma estadounidense
sonicwall sólo durante 2021 se
registraron 623 millones de ataques en
todo el mundo casi 20 intentos por
segundo eeuu es el país más afectado de
américa seguido de brasil colombia y
méxico
brasil fue el país de américa latina que
más disponibilidad o servicios
directamente expuestos en internet y
esos servicios no estaban adecuadamente
configurados eso es prácticamente una
invitación para que los criminales pm en
el ambiente a través del servidor que
fue puesto a disposición y consiguen
realizar un ataque de rawson
hasta la grabación de este programa el
último país que había sufrido un ataque
de este tipo a gran escala fue costa
rica donde el pasado 16 de mayo el grupo
ruso conti afectó una treintena de
entidades estatales
previamente la misma organización había
afectado el ministerio del interior de
perú revelando seguimientos a
funcionarios públicos los expertos
explican que américa latina es una
región potencialmente
y donde la ciberseguridad no está bien
desarrollada por lo que pidan una
inversión mayor en personal y sistemas
que garanticen una mayor seguridad
cambiamos de tema y vamos a túnez según
datos del banco mundial el 21% de la
población de este país no tenía acceso a
agua potable gestionada de forma segura
para 2020 por ello son múltiples las
iniciativas individuales que buscan
cambiar esta realidad una de ellas
esquimales donde buscan replicar lo que
ocurre con el rocío de la mañana
es esta máquina se llama cúmulos su
objetivo es potabilizar agua a partir de
la energía solar y del aire el concepto
es replicar el fenómeno del rocío de la
mañana así que qué es lo que ocurre y
vemos que el aire entra por aquí pasa
por el primer filtro de aire para
limpiarlo de contaminantes
luego entra en la máquina para enfriar
el agua y así replicamos el rocío de
ocio la tanda luz la primera máquina que
milos one se instaló en una escuela
primaria de la ciudad de vallada cerca
de la frontera con argelia pero aún
esperan la autorización del gobierno
para empezar a usarla según los
responsables este artefacto al que
llaman generador de agua atmosférica
puede producir entre 20 y 30 litros de
agua potable por día
a las 12 de los 17 países con mayor
escasez de agua en el mundo están en el
mundo árabe la escasez de agua y el
agotamiento de las aguas subterráneas
están aumentando debido al cambio
climático esta máquina puede hacer un
cambio de paradigmas ya que puede
producir agua del aire en marruecos
argelia túnez y arabia saudita puede
producir agua a partir de la humedad del
aire entonces es una de las soluciones
al problema de escasez de agua que
sufrimos el tsunami que finalizamos en
italia donde un robot perro es el
encargado de vigilar las ruinas de
pompeya se llama spot y es una
adaptación del robot creado por la
empresa boston robotics el perro es
capaz de deslizarse por espacios
estrechos e inseguros además es capaz de
recolectar y registrar datos útiles para
los expertos gracias a la cámara de 360
grados que tiene en lugar de cabeza
seguramente disfrutando de cuantos de
medios osados y spot es definitivamente
el resultado de lo mejor en robótica y
tecnología actual ya
el futuro es el futuro y los llamo hoy
lo vemos en la integración con lake a
vélez car que es un escáner láser que es
capaz de capturar la geometría de los
entornos por los que viaja spot
asimetría
de valor el valor agregado del robot es
que puede lidiar con entornos muy muy
difíciles frontal también
difícil debido a la capacidad de poder
manejarse sobre sus cuatro patas existir
es capaz de superar y sortear obstáculos
los responsables explican que hay zonas
del lugar que están inexploradas por lo
que apenas se están mapeando y
describiendo hay partes bajo tierra que
deben hacerse seguras porque luego se
abren a los turistas por todo ello hacer
la exploración con un robot es un valor
agregado además explota está en
capacidad de integrar otros sensores y
proporcionar información que no es
inmediatamente visible en el sitio como
la geometría o el estado de deterioro de
los entornos inexplorados o difíciles de
explorar
así llegamos al final de este espacio
les agradecemos su sintonía los
invitamos a continuar con nosotros en
france24 france24 puntocom
[Música]